why did we need to go to long beach and
shoot that scene
and it was just the location costs and
the permit costs and everything are 10
times the amount
why did you move to mexico
well
i think it's uh
for a lot of reasons really mexico um
is a as a very warm country it's a warm
place
and
personally before professionally i moved
there um to just kind of get away from
things
and to
kind of take a break from the hustle and
bustle i originally moved to cancun
mexico
lived there for several years
and did a lot of writing when i was
there
and then um
later i figured i can't really retire
at that age so i got closer to the
united states
and moved over to tijuana rosarito beach
area
and so at the end of the day
mexico is a
uh it's like a now it's my home i've
been there over 20 years and so it's
just it's more comfortable for me it's
easier to live there less stress things
of that sort and professionally um you
know
it's like a filmmaker's paradise you
know you can go anywhere you can shoot
anywhere it's got all kind of different
looks the mountains the hills the trees
i mean the uh the oceans the uh
deserts anything you want to shoot there
and and i think it's one of the only
places that can
at least on the western hemisphere that
can be truly cost effective without the
rebates
so you can still have a quote unquote
hollywood career whatever that looks
like entertainment career
and live and be an expat basically yeah
one of the things about where we are
which is tijuana just below the san
diego border
is that it's in theory the closest
international point to hollywood
in the world that means it's drivable so
we can drive
everything and everybody down from los
angeles without putting them on planes
but we're still you know working kind of
like a fraction of the la costs
so it's that closest international point
and
uh when we started the program
uh some years ago
many years ago now
but
that's what we were thinking about we're
thinking about how can we kind of not
have to do
la uh
restraints
la rules
but still be close enough to drive i
mean at the end of the day you can get
to from hollywood to the border in about
an hour and 45 minutes if traffic is
cooperative
i mean i
it takes longer than that to get from
like the valley to new to newport beach
a lot of the times you know i'm saying
so at the end of the day you can drive
everything in and move everybody on land
and don't have to put everybody on
planes and do all kinds of shipping and
things of that sort
and what about the
and this might be more of the american
media but that it's dangerous for
americans well i'll tell you
i said that is a good question
the
the the biggest hurdle that we have
as a film company
in tijuana mexico and mexico and
generally
is
what
the perception of
mexico is you have to convince almost
everybody that it's safe
now
it is safe we've done several films
there i think over
this will be our 29th coming up without
any incidents and i mean that no
incidents
but
you know every day you're bombarded with
this kind of negative
cartels and border problems and
all kinds of issues and you know
immigrants rushing the border and it
makes it feel super dangerous but it's
really not
and it's really difficult to explain
that to people or have people believe
that they kind of because they kind of
become entrenched in that belief you
know they kind of like well you know i
have a friend that this happened to and
i did this and it's very often it's not
true you know very often it's just kind
of this kind of
kind of tsunami of rumors
that are are being thrown out there um
because we
are there and we know it's there we we
understand
the lay of the land so
but it is something we have to make a
lot of assurances to
to actors and people that are coming
down
and we have a lot of security around we
don't always need it sometimes it's
honestly for the optics of it
but but we do have uh plenty of security
and when people get there they're just
like
you know like why where's this danger
everybody was talking about it it's just
really just very um
it's very normal very simple
and um just like anywhere else really
but you know you do have to take some
precautions or in a foreign country and
they don't have the civil infrastructure
that we have here so it's not like they
have the you can't two seconds later you
cop call the cops in two seconds later
they're at your door you know or two
minutes later it's a little bit
you gotta kind of know where you're
going and where to go and where not to
go but generally it's it's super safe
any um advice for people in terms of if
they are scouting locations or
they're actually going to shoot
uh coming with a sense of respect
you know like uh
i'm sure if any american goes to any
foreign country especially these days
maybe the past 20 years there's the
perception
is going to be different
ways we can conduct ourselves where we
give off an error of respecting someone
in
their homeland absolutely
what we try to do
on all the films is
make sure that anybody that's
interacting with the public
is a mexican person
it's kind of bad optics to have some
american
running in the street telling this guy
to move over there and hey close
close your doors they talk to each other
so there is a way to do it and there's
kind of like a protocol that we make
sure that we have
under
uh all our films
and
you know when you go there you
especially when you're getting a
location whatever you're you have to be
very very
uh polite
and uh you know
recognize that they probably don't
understand it
in the same way
that
maybe la locations would understand that
they think oh well it's going to be cool
we're going to film something they don't
know the
rush of people that are going to come in
there and how they come in and just do
all this crazy stuff and and they shut
everything down
um and so
there's protocols in that you have to
make sure that they understand what's
going on um you have to make sure that
and we always make sure that the deals
are made all the scouting deals all the
location deals are made from within my
mexican staff
we try not to go in there with this
kind of american voice
you know trying to make a bunch of deals
it's always better that way go smoother
and then if there's a problem they can
kind of talk to each other as countrymen
and and work it out rather than kind of
being the ugly american jumping in there
and saying hey you know this needs to be
like this and that needs to be like that
in some broken spanish accent it's it's
better if they do it and so i i always
defer and that's something you learn
over time i mean our first films you
know you just have a regular location
scout from from the valley going in
there and trying to make deals with
people didn't speak a word of spanish
and
it goes much better
the latter way
how long were you in mexico before you
decided to start a production company
well i was in there i was there
maybe let's call it around seven eight
years you know just personally
um
and i
i
was kind of just writing and trying to
figure out where my place would be
in in the film business
and so it's about seven about between
seven to ten years i think i was there
and um
the the genesis of it just if that's if
that skips the question i don't know but
the genesis of it
um
is that there was a company in baja
called baja films run by a guy by the
name of delfino lopez he was a
um just a regular guy but they had this
film company and they did
films
on super 16 remember super 16.
remember and it was um
they they were doing full 90 minute
films for nothing
and i was thinking in terms of and i'd
look at it and i was i was coming from
from l.a
and you know you're in l.a and you're at
coffee shops and everybody's trying to
figure out where to get their film
together and how we're going to get
financed and everything else and and
while we're doing that these guys are
doing a film a month
at film every two months
on film 90-minute film now
you can't get through one of them i mean
they're not
very good i mean it in our as far as the
way that they're done
narco cinema it's actually quite
famous
and um
but they were doing these very
interesting 90-minute films and so i
said i just started to think
you know
what if
we just added
american storyline
maybe one or two american actors
guy coming down to save his daughter
guy getting down there gets drunk gets
caught up with the cartels things like
that
and and some of the movies that we all
know movies like man on fire movies like
sicario movies like some of the parts of
traffic
and
i thought
you know i can go and try to figure out
a way to fit into that
system in los angeles where i can come
down there and work with these guys
bring a couple elements down and just
keep working
and i decided that that would be the
best bet
in other words
it may not be as glamorous
in the beginning but
we're getting things done we're proving
our worth we're creating a real we're
doing
we're just staying busy
and you realize how difficult it is for
people to stay busy and you realize also
then
that a lot of actors will come down and
work for you if they're not doing
anything those come down and
and and say sure if they like the script
and mexico especially tijuana and those
border areas it's kind of a really super
gritty
space and so it's very interesting to
see americans
move through that space like like i said
mentioned before movies like man on fire
um sicario things like that where you
have uh kind of interesting border
stories about uh and there and and and
not to mention
the cartel tropes that are that are
there cartels make very very
good villains cartel leaders uh they're
intelligent they're not you know they're
organized they're not just crazy people
cutting people up they're usually very
very good villains and so there's a lot
of stories in there and so
we just started
decided to start stop talking about it
and start making the movies
when did you make your first movie in
mexico first movie in mexico was uh
produced and not directed did a film
called la lina or the line
i wrote it produced it
it started andy garcia ray liotta a
whole bunch of people
issai morales
um
and uh that was in uh night in 2007.
we did in 2007 it was released in 2009
very very interesting experience
some of the some of the things that we
had an idea to do
we didn't do meaning we're going to do
it really small and it wasn't it was
pretty it was pretty big we set
everything up in la and took it down to
mexico and it was it's quite an
experience it was good but a very very
very good
experience and a good film in my opinion
so you had to prove yourself
that you could take this crew down there
you said you were the producer but not
the director and convince people that it
was safe and that this would work yeah
and we were super bubbled on that film
this is before i really started to make
mexican films mexican films we the first
idea you have a lot of times is you just
say okay hey i'm gonna um
you know set things up like anybody else
would set it up and get a dp and get a
sound piercing and then we're gonna
travel down to tijuana and do this film
uh so we were like in a bubble
and we it was an expensive bubble in
comparison to what
we could have done it for
but uh it was a good learning experience
and we had a lot of things now that we
know we didn't need
um and
it was it
was an interesting way to film there but
it's not this kind of organic mexico
filming like our subsequent films were
um
so you know it's kind of like if you go
anywhere you go to romania you go to
italy you know you grew up in the states
usually you get some local crew there
and then you go and you take your major
keys and everybody goes down there and
everything else like that
so
that was called
la lina the line
and it was a
quite a great experience
and what were some of the things that
you realized later that you didn't need
we realized
later that we did not need um
you know all the
we didn't need to first of all we didn't
need to create a base camp everywhere we
went
um
we
shuttled around this huge 17 truck base
camp because we just thought that's what
we needed so we went we had to get
parking lots and
blocking streets and have this big
caravan of cars and everything else
um and
uh that's one of them and the and second
and most important is crew there's
plenty of good crew there but we
you know had to take everybody from the
states all the keys and then the keys
said well you know i just don't feel
comfortable unless i have my second
and then they said well and we have a
person that will work and they're an
assistant and so we didn't quite
understand
how much all that cost
um
you know it just seemed pretty simple
but filming out of the country is very
much different than filming
in hollywood or in l.a it's not like you
can just give somebody a call time hey
call times in north hollywood at seven
o'clock and be there
you have to
drive them there they have to have
per diem they've got to have you have
food they have to have all kinds of uh
coordination of movement
um
and it's it's a lot of work so it's
you're
it's it's probably double the work um to
have everybody there to coordinate all
the the travel and
the transportation to set to and from
set everything else so we we realized we
we didn't need all those people we could
have we could crew up in mexico with an
incredibly competent and talented
mexican crew
and and then not have to
have the expense and drama frankly of
bringing people from the states
and you also said you learned over time
maybe or or maybe that was out of the
project that taught you that if you had
uh people from mexico that it would go
smoother with the locals with whatever
law enforcement was around with whoever
was enforcing this film shooting
absolutely absolutely it would have gone
smoother and less expensive right and we
learned that you know those are lessons
you learn and um was the first film and
so we we we were just kind of figuring
it out taking a lot of advice um you
know people are saying hey you need to
do this you need to do that and you hire
somebody and then he calls his
friends and people he knows and you know
and then um and then everybody
you know crews up like that where um and
uh it was a full union show
and and as you know when you're a union
show they don't work for the producers
they work for their department head
and um and then
and they work for
the payroll company so they're the
employer record
so you know
you know sometimes they do what you say
sometimes they don't
and so but we kept it together
all together and it was but it was a
good learning experience and
and um you know if you have enough money
it's fine you can bring people anyway
and james bond movies and x-men they
film all over the world and they bring
this whole
you know
big
machine with them that's like a city and
they have to
um but
you know
if you have that kind of money that's
what you do with it i guess
and then you create your own little
bubble of your comfort wherever you go
so
in
but most people don't have that not an
indie film have that kind of money and
so that money is usually not the best
money spent
if i'm honest
and so was it after your first film as
the producer that you realize i don't
need to go back to la or you had already
made that decision
i mean go back to la for crew a crew is
one thing or or to to piece together the
project and and pitch the idea maybe but
in terms of living
oh no no i realized no i that
you know we did a little piece of the
movie in in l.a
the first movie la lena the line
and um
the cost of that
one week
was astronomical in relation to what it
was the rest of the four weeks
it's astronomical and so you realize
why didn't we just do the whole film in
mexico
why did we need to go to long beach and
shoot that scene
and it was just the location costs and
the permit costs and everything are 10
times the amount
so the like i said the the if they're
the learning
moment the teachable moment
in that would be
to trusted the system and just take
everything there and do most of the
things there
and
and put most of the stuff on the screen
as opposed to
putting so much money into creating a
like a bubble that makes everybody you
know comfortable